hello and welcome to five design
patterns
with typescript and this is the original
design patterns book
it was released in 1994.
i think i read it in 95. it's a
fantastic book the idea is that there
are
uh the same way that an architect has
and i'm talking about
like a house architect has you know a
basic
construction layout for what a good
house how a good house is constructed
and how the parts and pieces fit
together where the bathroom should be
where the
living room and the the kitchen should
be and all that
we have similar sorts of things in how
we construct software
in what are some pretty time-tested
patterns that people can can leverage so
they have the book
separated into three different big parts
they've got
creational which is things that you know
ways to create
objects structural these are ways that
you know things uh the uh
components fit together and then
behavioral which would be
you know kind of temporal things like
you know commands
and stuff like that manages state over
time
one thing i would say don't let's not
over emphasize the whole
object oriented design part of this the
oop
part of this certainly in typescript and
in javascript
you're not gonna we're not gonna use
necessarily classes unless we need to
uh so a few of these will do with
functions a few will do with classes
you know as we go we'll see hi jack how
you doing
okay so i've got a little starter
thing here we're gonna go make an
in-memory database that's kind of what
we're gonna design
our or look at different design patterns
around uh that actually
comes from a um
interview i heard somebody had to take
was basically you know design an
in-memory database
and then kind of adding on to it from
there so we're going to look
at a bunch of different patterns we're
going to look at
the factory pattern the singleton
pattern which is incredibly popular
the observer pattern or what we now call
uh pub sub publish and subscribe which
is obviously
huge uh and then there's also the
visitor and strategy pattern and if we
get through all of that
i'll actually give you one more and make
it
a full six so we'll see we'll see here
we go hey alex good to see you
happy friday so happy to have you here
um is it okay to use both class and
function
with state in the same component uh
oh interesting um
well you know like when you're talking
about react um
yeah i mean i guess you could use a
class-based component
as part of a sub a sub-component you
could use a functional component sure no
problem
uh but we're not going to react in this
one we're just going to talk about
just generic typescript so the first
thing we need to do
when we talk about building out an
in-memory database is to define what we
want the scheme
the interface of that database to be so
we're going to define an interface
we'll call that database and it's going
to have a getter
which is going to get by id i'm just
gonna go bring over my code here so i
can make sure i don't go down rabbit
hole i can't actually get out of
uh it's gonna get an item by id
and what's it gonna return so we need to
have some sort of type what what kind of
things are we putting into our database
so we're going to use
t and say that we're going to make this
generic so we're going to learn some
typescript generics which is great
and we're also going to have a setter
for our yeah that's going to add
something to our database we're going to
use
it's going to be an id based database
it's going to be like nosql
uh hi random um
and it's going to be looked up by id so
we're going to have some sort of data
coming in
a new value or a new new object
and that's going to come in as that and
then it's going to turn a void
but in order for set to do that new
value has to have an id
so we're going to create a thing called
base record
that has an id in it and we're going to
say that whatever this
is it needs to at least extend base
record
so that basically says it hey you got to
at least have
an id in whatever you're going to put
into this database
okay so let's actually create an
in-memory database of that so i'm going
to create a new database i'll call it in
memory database
and it's going to implement if i can
ever type
the database with the given record or
type
that we want and it's going to have in
it
a private database of a you know where
you have a record
that has a string is the id and then
whatever that type is
and i guess at this point we're going to
need to say that we have
t on there this is not um what we're
gonna do so
okay um all right
and let's see we're gonna have a center
and a getter
so let's do that
cool
and what's this going to do this is
going to be the easiest thing ever it's
just going to say this.db
it's going to take that new value and
take the id out of there
and set it to new value
and oops hold on that's not right there
we go
okay so again this is going to extend
base record so we know that we have
that
and then to get it we're going to do
this.db
and then give it the id
and there you go so that should be in
fact actually this point
it should be t or undefined
so there if you want to pass your
interview that's actually like
the smallest in memory database i can
think of
um all right let's go and actually try
this out let's say uh
let's go create a pokemon db
and in order to use that generic we're
going to say that
we're going to use pokemon
and because it's got an id that extends
id on the base record and there you go
so now i can do pokemon.db
and then give it a new pokemon it's id
is a
bulbasaur and its attack
is i don't know 50 and its defense is
10 and then let's
console log out the pokemon db
get and then the
bulbasaur yeah okay thanks
vs code for ending me on that cool all
right let's go over here
and then i can just yarn start
oops hold on oh i know what i did
i gotta remove my no modules hey john
good to see you
everybody excited gonna have a great
weekend-ish thing
all right let's let's start that up okay
cool
so yarn start in this case all it's
doing is just running ts node which is
the typescript
node uh wrapper on
source index.ts and there you go
so we can put an item into our pokemon
database and we can get one back out
so the first thing we're going to look
at is the factory
pattern so let's say that i want a way
of
requesting a database from
from a a global source and it will
either give me say
an in-memory database if i that's the
way that i have it configured
or to give me a mysql database or it'll
give me a file based database
that's the idea of a factory pattern is
that this factory is going to hide
the which thing that you're going to
implement that with
the class you're going to implement that
with from
the code so let's do that let's say
function create database
and it too is going to take that that
base record
and then in here this is really cool
actually i can just define
a new in-memory database like that
and return it this is kind of neat
actually one of the cool things
that we can use in uh in typescript
what font am i using in vs code what oh
well let's take a look
settings this is the apollo midnight
theme
and i'm currently using mona lisa
mono lisa i actually think that's a paid
for font
sorry about that um but there are a lot
of good open source alternatives
so there you go okay
so in order to do that i'm just going to
call create database
and that's going to give me back a
pokemon db
as a as a class which is so cool
one of the really cool things that you
can do in
in uh in javascript you can basically
create
classes automatically or yeah at runtime
and so we're going to do is create
pokemon db this time lowercase and then
just do new pokemon db
uh all right so why isn't that working
all right it's let's just call that you
know
oh pokemon nice
all right i'm not real happy with the
fact that it's upper and distinguished
only by a lower upper and lower case p
but we're not going to leave it that
long so there you go so that is our
first
pattern this is the factory
pattern in c plus plus
which is what you'd have when in 1994
when the book first came out
uh this would be primarily like a
factory primarily
a a class which had mostly static
methods on it
which would then give you the instances
of those classes
depending on what you asked for so if
you asked for it it would be able to
have like a static
create database we don't need to do that
obviously in
typescript you're going to have to have
that kind of public static thing you
could
but i think this is more in line with
what you expect
out of a typescript application so we're
going to interpret
our design patterns in the context of
typescript we're not just going to go
and like kind of
make c classes that are implemented in
typescript
okay so the next one we're going to look
at
is a singleton so we do this a lot in
applications we create
singletons a lot like a redux store and
a react application as a singleton
when we've been looking at state
managers as we've gone through a lot of
the
state managers over the past couple
weeks a lot of those are singletons
so what is a singleton well a singleton
means that there can be only one
you know kind of like the highlander
right there can be only one
in this case there can be only one
pokemon db
so the easiest way to do that
in this one would be to have this
factory pattern return
that singleton oh yeah if your code is
great i was actually on for
most of my videos i would say we're on
fuhrer code
i was actually just kind of going around
looking for different mono space fonts
and i was like oh i kind of like that
mono
mono lisa one a lot so i'm gonna go buy
it
i did actually have to go and tweak this
theme though so that we get these
really nice italics and but it's not
that big of a deal to tweak it and if
you want
i can put that up in adjust for you if
you if you really like this theme and
you want if you want to use it
okay so let's go and do a singleton here
and there's a couple of different ways
to do this in
in javascript and typescript so the i
think the most native way would be at
this point to say
that we just want a new in-memory
database right now
and we want to return that and so now
we would just have this one pokemon db
and you
have it as an export on your module
yeah and
there you go that's your singleton so
you
only ever call this create database once
and away you go
there is a more
c plussy way to do this you could do you
could actually make the
constructor on this private
and then have a public a static instance
of this
of a memory database and then just do in
new in-memory database
like that and then again we would
let me just change this out and really
this is just kind of up to you
which way you want to play it so i'll do
a memory database again like that
and then at this point i would get back
that pokemon db
and i could say pokemondb.instance
and again that would make sure that you
only ever have
one instance of a pokemon so there's a
couple of different ways to do that
in uh javascript and typescript
yeah i'm with you flatline boy that is a
tough one when it comes to singletons
there's an issue where
you know you have this singleton right
and you want to go and
throw some data at it and then test it
and then in another test you want to go
and throw some other data at it
and then do another test but you want it
to be essentially restarted each time
there is a way i think to make just
flush
out the module cache so you can
essentially re-initialize
the singleton but yeah not great
so there are i will say use the
singleton with some care just like i
said in the
uh brad video way way way back
um the singleton is something you should
use a lot of care on
what i tend to do is if i'm doing
something like this this
single value system i'll also export
like
a a cleaner function that will go and
like return the the singleton back to a
known
origin origin state and then i can use
that for testing
okay so what do we look at so far we've
looked at the factory pattern
we've looked at the singleton pattern
and now and this is so good this is my
favorite one i'm sorry random rabbit
i'm i'm glad to have you here but and
thanks for hanging out
um we're gonna look at my favorite one
and that's the observer pattern so this
is
we know this is event listeners and pub
sub
and there's all of these different words
for it but i'm going to give you
actually a
really really really nice pattern for
this so
we're going to create a
observer so that's what they call it in
the book you can call it whatever you
want you can call it as i said you can
call
pub sub you can call it whatever and
we're going to create a function called
createobserver so this is going to give
us a little
uh object that we can then use
to publish and subscribe to if you watch
the effector video
that i just put out on wednesday i was
really inspired by that
by their interface and this is kind of
along that line
so let's go and do this it's going to
return
a subscribe
method i'm just going to take a listener
and that listener is going to have an
unsubscribe
and then it's going to take a publish
which is what i'm going to use or
what the publisher is going to use to
actually send out an event so call you
know
event and then that's going to return a
void
but this is not great you know typing
wise so let's go and add some types so
first thing i'm going to do is define a
type for a listener
and it's going to take an event type
and it's going to then
get called with that event type and
return void so that's basically
when i subscribe right this is the
function that i need to give it i need
to give it a function it's going to take
an event
type and then return a void
pretty easy so let's go and
take this event type and also use it in
our create observer
so lots of fun generics going on here
so this is going to be our listener with
that event type
and then finally publish is also going
to take that event type
so this is a really nice little function
here it's basically going to
maintain a list of observers and allow
us to publish and subscribe from that
list so let's go and do that
we're going to say that we have a
listeners array
all right and it's going to start off
empty
and then we're going to return our what
we want out here so we're going to
make a subscribe
and a lot of typing on this one there we
go i'll just copy and paste that
and it will return a void
like that so what does it need to do
well it needs to push
on to the listeners
the new listener coming in and then it's
going to return
that unsubscribe method so that's that's
the way i'm going to unsubscribe from
everything
and we'll set listeners equal to
listeners.filter
so we'll just remove the the listener
that we just got
if they unsubscribe so it's going to
take a listener and we're going to say
hey
is that equal to the one that we brought
in if so
there we go let me get rid of all these
lines here for a second
by just putting in a placeholder for
that
just so we can take a look okay so let
me just go through one more time on this
so we've got our array of listeners we
initialize it to
an empty array this is what's called a
closure in javascript
so this listener is going to be specific
to this particular
return and then
we're going to return a subscribe
function which takes a listener
and returns a uh
hold on there you go all right
claim some syntax errors and it's going
to turn an unsubscribe function
this is very similar to use effect the
way that use effect works
use effect takes a function and if that
function returns a function
then when the use effect is uh when the
the component unmounts
then that use effect is that that is
returned
or called
[Laughter]
well let me catch up with a flat line
here they gang four bucks they tell you
visitor pattern yeah
yes well we're gonna get to the visitor
pattern although it's so easy to do in
javascript
it's really not even a thing
okay so there we go and then the the all
that
unsubscribe is going to do is just
basically take the listeners and just
filter out what we got and that's
just going to remove that particular
method from the array and i think this
is actually a nicer pattern
than what you do with windowed our
document or element add event listener
you have to give it back the same
function again
in order to unsubscribe which i think is
a pain i think this is actually
a nicer interface okay
so let's say i have an event i want to
publish it now
so i just want to go through all those
listeners and for each one
i'm going to have a listener function
and i'm just going to call it
with that event that's it that is all
that i need to do
so really cool so
what do i need to do well i need to go
and try and put i'm going to
add this to my database
so before you set a value and after you
set a value
you're going to get an event right we'll
call that one uh
let's see before set event
and it'll take a type and it's going to
give you the current value
and then the new incoming value it seems
like a decent
thing to do and then with the
after set event that's going to tell you
that i updated and just tell you what
the new value is
seems pretty reasonable
so let's go down here and add on to our
interface for the database we'll say
we have an on before add this is how i'm
going to go and add an event listener
and i'll say we have a listener
and here's some fun stuff so we're going
to have a listener
okay and it's going to take a before
set event
nice right so good and then it's going
to return
that unsubscribe function so it's
starting to look like stl
if you have flashbacks to uh the c plus
plus
so basically all we're saying is your
listener function should be a listener
that listens for a before set event
and then on the after ad
and do the same thing we're going to do
it for
after set event now of course we don't
actually have this
in our in memory database so let's go
and do that
all right so we'll go down here and
start implementing this out
all right cool but it's not we're
actually returning anything so let's
actually go and
use our really nifty cool create
observer so we're going to create a
private before
add listeners
and we'll do that create observer thing
and it's going to take a
before set event
oops and then after add listeners
all right after set the event there you
go cool
all right so how do we do a
sub a a subscribe well we do subscribe
see how nice that is and then we just
give it the listener
same thing for this
all right
okay coolio but we need to return that
so we have a way to unsubscribe and now
let's use it so
now we've got a way to listen to stuff
but we have nothing that's publishing
so let's go do that so before we add
we want to call publish and cnn we're
getting a really nice
hint here so let's see new value is
going to be the
incoming value named new value
which is nice and then we're going to
take the existing value
which is whatever that is
okay cool and then down here we're going
to do it
after add
again publish and this time we're just
going to give it the value
well the new value which is actually the
new value okay
there we go cool nice
that is a second bird that's gone in my
window in this many days
all right okay cool so let's actually
try this out so we're gonna
we're over here on set so let's go and
add another one
i'll call it i don't know i spinosaur
i think that's from like jurassic park
three or something and it's it's bigger
it's got a hundred
and it's got a defense of 20 it's not
very good defense
but in the meantime we want to go and
subscribe to our database so let's go
here let's go to pokemon db instance
and then on before or let's do
on before add do we want to do it
nah let's do after add it doesn't really
matter
and it's going to take a function
that's going to take a pokemon
or a value let's see a new value
and we're just going to console log that
out
cool and let's see how it does it work
all right
nice okay so all right let me uh
here this is a little confusing don't
need to do that
so if it works what it should be doing
is it should set bulbasaur
it should set our listener and then
anytime a new one gets added
then we automatically say we output it
which is good
looks looks great and then if we want to
unsubscribe
now we can i guess call that down here i
guess
but let's put this up front
and this time we'll see that bulbasaur
comes out
and then but not spinosaur
let's give it a try
yeah perfect so we
are subscribing at the beginning that's
giving us back an unsubscribe
method or function and then we
set a value that's going to fire off our
after add
and then we unsubscribe and then we do
some more setting
and it's really really nice very clean
so there you go there's a nice observer
pattern for you i think it's
very very type safe and it also uses
makes the best use i would say of a
standard javascript paradigm which is a
closure
and that's how this this listeners works
you have that
listener is captured essentially by this
function
or the return of this function so
everyone maintains its own list for you
it's very clean
all right so that's three
patterns down got two more to go
the first one i would say is the visitor
pattern
so in order to do that we want to have a
way to visit every
every element in our database so let's
just call it
visit um all right and it's going to
take a function
let's see how i did this before
all right well it says a visitor
and it takes an item and returns a voip
all right that's gonna be a function
there you go so when you do visit it's
gonna go through each one of the objects
in our database
and send it off to you so let's do that
let's do
visit
and we'll go down here
and this is really tough so the object
values
of our database so it's
we've got a hash which is a database and
this is just going to get all those
values
and then we're going to go through each
one of them using for each
and fire off to our visitor it's really
that easy so
that's one of the things about the gang
of four book and how it fits in with
uh what we do today the gang of four
book being
out there in 1994 means that it's it's
kind of in the genesis of
about of a lot of what we've seen and
it's been kind of
now built into frameworks so things like
four
each are really just the visitor pattern
from the gang of four book
and it's really cool because we can
apply those to all kinds of different
data sets right so you can apply for
each to
you know different you know different
types of data so all right let me just
uh look over here
ah denoin's felt oh that's a good combo
i like that
all right let's go try out our visitor
pattern so let's go down here to our
our singleton instance of pokemon db
and then we will visit
each one of those
and put out its uh its name how about
that
cool so let's do it
run it again nice
so now in the database we've got the
bulbasaur and we got the spinosaur
and that just gives us a really nice way
of traversing
whatever our data structure is and
that's what
visitor is supposed to do it's supposed
to hide from you the implementation
details of how you've stored everything
and just give you a way
to hey you i give you some a traversal
method or i give you a
a method you call me back with
everything you found
so that's that's the visitor pattern and
it's pretty standard it's now baked into
almost everything we do
along with the publish and subscribe
event stuff as well okay and then the
fifth one i want to look at
is the strategy pattern and that's
because i use this one actually
a lot so the strategy pattern
is an interesting one basically the idea
is
it's kind of a play on visitor and a
little bit more so
let's say that we want a way to find the
best of uh
of the pokemon in the pokemon in the
database and return it so we're gonna
say we want the best
record i guess we'll make it generic
we'll call it generic that's yeah or
select best how about that
so of the data in the database select
the best
and so for that we're gonna have a score
strategy we're gonna have a way for you
to call
to specify a function
that given an item is going to give me
back some sort of number
and then at the end of that i'm going to
tell you which one scored best
pretty easy so the first thing i need to
do is have a
have somewhere to store all that so i'm
going to create a thing called found
or variable called found and it's going
to say well what's the
what's the highest score that i've got
the maximum number and what was that
associated with so that's going to be
the type or undefined and we're going to
initialize that to
0 as the maximum and then the item to
undefined
and return whatever we found
but of course we know we need to do
something with that so let's go through
and look at all the values in the
database
and then call reduce on that
now this is my favorite reduce is
awesome i love reduce
with reduce you can basically do
everything else
so reduce is going to take the current
found value and the item
and it's going to call that score
strategy one that's i'm gonna say well
what what do i get for the score well i
got to call the
score strategy on the current item
and then if the score that i got back is
better than what i have
then i'll set my maximum to that score
and set my item
to whatever that was
but of course we need to initialize it
with something so let's initialize with
found
and let's see so
why is that not happy that should be
happy happy happy happy
uh what does it tell me all right
f max okay
you know what i'm gonna do i'm just
gonna copy this over and see what
happens
yeah okay what was my problem oh i would
die i didn't return it that's what it
was
okay so return f i think that was it
yeah
cool okay so this is great this is
this is how reduce works reduce goes
through an array
it starts off with your initial value
which in this case is found so max
equals zero
and item equals undefined it then gives
you
that value in each iteration along with
the item and then you do something with
that item and return a new value so
people use this for adding numbers up
they use it for doing all kinds of stuff
reduce is actually phenomenal
hi jase coders so martin fowler let me
just check on what flatline's saying
uh yes vlad i will definitely put this
code up on github
and martin fowler a new guy around not
new though inventor
dependency injection and other cool
stuff
okay yeah we'll agree to disagree on
dependency injection a little bit
flatline
i've been bitten in the butt enough
times by dependency injection
but i do understand that like like react
context
is basically dependency injection so
that's fine
anywho all right so
this is a really cool function now we
got this select best so what we can do
with a strategy pattern
is i can go down here and i can say cool
for my pokemon db i'm gonna go and
select the best
by defense so let's see i'm gonna go
it's gonna give me the defense value
nicely hinted there
and i'm just gonna return that i'm gonna
say hey
cool so this is the best defense
pokemon defensive pokemon
and then if i were to do this again and
say that i want the attack
this would be the best uh attack pokemon
and let's make sure that they are
different so okay bulbasaur's got a 10
for defense
in spy okay but let's make uh let's make
let's make bulbasaur have a better
defense how about that so the best
defense would be
bulbasaur and the best offense would be
spinosaur i guess that makes sense
having seen jurassic park 3 i can i can
say that that's probably the case
so let's see uh console.log
best attack is going to be
the that one oh look at that
give me even the question mark like that
that's nice and then best defense
is gonna be that guy
all right let's run it see see if it
actually works
cool so the best defense is a bulbasaur
and the best attack is a spinosaur
nice but isn't that a really nice way
to kind of hide or make it easy
for you now you can start thinking about
okay what am i
what's my scoring criteria it allows you
to kind of focus on the problem
as opposed to the mechanics of how do i
iterate through this database how do i
get all the records yada yada
i mean i know that we're working on an
in-memory database and it's super super
small
but imagine if that was like a big
paginated database or like a firebase
and you got to go and get all the pages
and all sort of stuff
it hides all that it hides all the
mechanics of that and all that
for you so you don't need to think about
it
all you got to do is think about hey you
know what what's my strategy here
uh for defining you deciding which is
best
so that's a really nice uh pattern
and and there you go so five quick
design patterns for you let's just go
through
so we had a factory pattern which
allowed us to create a
generic database that that matched
whatever
our our interface was
actually hold on let me uh going out out
on that so
it's complete
cool all right um we've got a
what was the next one you did we did a
singleton pattern
by doing that instance up here
by making a static instance as i say
there's multiple ways to do that you
don't need to do that that way but this
is a very
kind of traditional gang of four way to
do this
uh that we then did the awesome observer
pattern and
there's this excellent you know kind of
pattern here that you can use
to give it a publish and subscribe
uh let's see what would happen if we
they both had the same attack uh let me
just go
like and then we also did the visitor
and strategy pattern
and let me uh let's see if they both
have the same
attack i am going to guess
that what's going to happen is it's
going to be bulbasaur because the first
one in is going to win
so let's take a look
yeah so bulbasaur wins and the reason is
because
it's one little thing here if score is
greater than
f max then we set it and in this case 50
50
you know where both values are 50. it's
not going to be greater than it's just
going to be equal to but if we did
greater than or equal to like that
i know it's a little hard to tell it's a
ligature but basically great equal to or
greater than
and then it would pick the last one so
in this case
you'd pick spinosaur hope that helps
but yeah uh so really cool pattern there
i've used strategy for a bunch of
different things
basically if you want to kind of
separate concerns between the stuff that
iterates
through data versus the stuff that
manipulates the data
the strategy pattern and the visitor
pattern are great ways to do that
okay well it looks like we have a little
bit more time so i'm gonna go for six
we're gonna try we're gonna do this
we're gonna make this happen uh
okay so in our starter project
there is a a json file that's got some
additional pokemon in it and there is a
a loader which basically loads
from a file so you give it a file name
and you give it a
a class called a record handler
that in turn takes it has an add record
method on it and what it does is this
loader function then calls
that add record for each one of the
records in that that file
cool so what we want to do is
adapt and that's where this is the
adapter pattern
we are going to adapt our database to
connect to that loader uh
function so here we go we have loader
and we're going to call it let's let's
call it up front let's call
right after we initialize the pokemon db
let us
call loader and we'll give it the local
file name of data.json
cool but now we need to give it that
record handler class so
let's create a new class called pokemon
db adapter and it's going to ex
implement the
record handler for
with pokemon as our data type
and what we need to do we need to
implement add record
and what what's that going to take well
it's going to take
a record of type t
in this case which is going to be a
pokemon
but we'll specify that anyway oh wow
that was interesting
pokemon
and with that we are just going to call
pokemon db
instance to get our our singleton and
then
set that incoming record
so this is going to adapt our
pokemon database to our loader system
so all we need to do is create a new one
of those
and send it off let's take a look and
see how we do
uh okay so you know what let's go and
add in
our our after add value
subscription in there and we'll get rid
of a couple other things just uh
so we don't get so much in the console
okay cool let's run this and see
see how it do
cool okay so i brought in minosaur
toughassor and bulbasaur
that those are loaded in by the loader
which has that adapter class
to adapt our database to our loader
system
and then at the end of this we went
through and we did a visitor pattern
where we
output every one of their ids so we can
see them all so
that's another cool one you see
adapters a lot when it comes to um
if for example in the react context of
doing
uh react components the wrap you know
third-party client
third-party js
libraries things like that so
yes we don't really call it necessarily
the adapter pattern but we do
kind of end up doing that in real life a
lot if we're connecting one day
one library to another that's when you'd
use the the adapter pattern
cool all right well there you go
uh six different design patterns
all in one video pretty cool um
yeah if you have any more questions let
me know
uh i did want to you know before kind of
wrapping this up
i just want to say of course feel free
to like and share the video with your
friends
hit the subscribe button if you haven't
already
i added a new thing you can actually buy
me a coffee which ends up supporting the
channel
for like seo research and thumbnail
generation and things like that
kind of the ongoing cost of the running
this channel
you can do that there's a link to that
in the description
and uh but besides that you know uh be
happy healthy and safe but of course
i'll stick around if you have any
comments or questions
uh just feel free to put those in the
video and are in the comments and
you can keep on going for a little bit
dm design thanks for all the great
resources pride super helpful thank you
um sean carroll i don't think i've ever
heard of sean carroll before i'll have
to take a look
alright cool i hope he's got a decent
voice
uh yeah all right any other
questions was this helpful uh have you
guys done any of this does it give you a
little background
on design patterns and why they're
useful
let me know drop them in the comments
okay well looks like we're wrapping up
so
uh cool i'm gonna jump on over to the
discord server
you can have a chat with me over here
i'm going to be over in the
general pretty soon and uh
i'll see you over there alright bye guys
have a great